[Applauso]
per utilizzare gli storici
stiamo mica è oggi una challenge epica
speciale 700mila facciamo lo slime
gigante abbiamo messo su con la bianca
che con la trasparente cosa che sia un
bellissimo mix e poi abbiamo tantissimi
crediti sono più di cento non portati
battle abbiano dicendo non più di 200
venderemo tantissimi talenti
in più questa volta invece di mettere un
pochino degli ingredienti dovremmo
svuotamento di verde spero non è
capitato di tutto non giovano metterne
un pochino le altre volte contro la
spunta su tutto quindi vicino a uno
strike su un politico molta fatica testa
per precisare la ruota visto che sono
leva frizione
qualche cosa ci fosse di tosse vischiosi
di bendato oppure scambio di curate come
vecchi tempi migliori
mettetevi comode video fino alla fine
perché poi dovrete votare se vinco io
il celeste o semicentrale di grosso
batte scarpi mezzo pratico
con la clijster umbri per due quindi che
questo nelle due il fiocco in serie a le
touquet fortunato di già quindi quali
segni ma io se ti dà tutto se lo scambio
non io posso rovinare questa per poi
praticamente darlo tel
quindi se riesce a non perdere dicevamo
che viaggiando e poi è sempre il mio
dito
mettiamo in maniera conservativa del
blue me di vita e ben piova dal cielo
club savoia sappia perché va bene
[Musica]
colorata occhi chiusi o una brutta
sensazione cose che devo scegliere occhi
chiusi
allora colorati abbiamo sia petti va
dietro via questi che sono al gozzo
linea era certo quello di sperando che
non mi capiti bene
comunità chimica per il colore blu
comunque sì perché negli altri c'è anche
il nero e marrone quindi le riceverà
[Musica]
sempre perché sappiamo che qualsiasi
altro colore nero 900 occhi chiusi si
ripeterà e questo che sono stati beccati
capitolo nomine altri tutto nella colla
twitter a sabbione grande persona non è
già uno slang ward che guarda colla se
insomma che non scende perché tuttavia è
rimasta poco ma che minaccia di votare
no
[Musica]
che bello sly uno che sto facendo
poi dopo non ti lamentare saremo uno
scambio di beni
il viola è sparito perché sono troppo
bianco a troppo celeste che vediamo il
mio giallo ecco qua il giallo lo svuoto
tutto
[Musica]
wow sta diventato tutto giorni nissimo
pò metallizzato un po grossi sara
bellini così cordonale se non mi
capitano tricolori brutti o qualche
ingrediente brutto
io sono diventata di in giallo
praticamente in bianco accogliente
europa
[Musica]
da mantenere ciao colorante occhi chiusi
della linea un po di colore che ti
capitano tutti quei metodi sono i
verdetti club che gli occhi oppure
arrivo quasi tutto questo mettiamo mai
fatto da solo tutti qua ok corretta e
sicura bianco dove capita
basta così io metto tutto il mio
pigmento bianco tutto ma è sporco e un
bianco sporco impianto per lato vediamo
come tidei a parole nessuno ma di natale
ma appare già malato di mente perché
senza lo stop ha retto ma ha commentato
in ballo più forte dopo quando la tv si
vedrà meglio giallo canarino che non
metteva mai diventa questo celestino
[Musica]
facciamo perché è diventato progetto è
che il celestino sotto sto diventato di
rigetto ecco perché sono stato fortunato
con il fischia la stellina di essere
votata chiaro adesso diventa una roccia
quale mi piace in più finora il miglior
la rosa di vita o il mio giallo di
amerino sono in città bella e partirà
occhi gibellini e ora non per decorare
palline kenya energico gli occhi abbiamo
la nuova maschera di acer catino sei un
babbo ma ora mi fanno cambiare un
maschio e una femmina hai fatto
ma chi è fortunato pigmento occhi chiusi
ok per colore disco verde aspetto la
pasta la tenente guido sono qui ok non è
che vi farete lavare nello zaino questo
che ha una consistenza strana ancora lo
giocano discorso questo perché mettiamo
però che ben presto i giornali urbinati
di opporsi stato da tre anni canta più
della mia tesi diventati pronta si
metteranno sempre il mio pigmento d'ora
auto penso che riuscirà bellissimo con
il pigmento che sembra proprio oro 24
carati
spero che libereremo bellissimo
perplesso d'ora
oddio pura cera parlare sia uscirà un
goal line gigantesco se solo non mi
capita qualche ingrediente schifo e
bellissimo mappa dovrai competere con
quetta
le stesse che sono tutte incollate
sull'abruzzo tutte le mettiamo giuste
ovvero allegria
mardy ballini malissimo
avete mai la famiglia o girare allora
braccio e perché la prima cosa che tutti
[Musica]
dei coloranti scegli tu o fortunato
salvadori arcadio per fortuna solo run
tese lituana perché sentito brutti
esteso di farmi vedere un po trash
abbiamo un po di arancione rosso per
cento test scambio città per loro
ok versiamo tu ma il tuo colore
preferito è il bloom che certo non posso
nelle tue cose pur con i limiti piazze
bruxelles ha affatto marrazzo io
purtroppo è fortissimo basse che colore
dolcedo sta uscendo un po pesca è
diventato un po pesca una festa
vitalizza anzi non sta tornando giallo
bona capisce più niente il comparso quel
colore è piaciuto come quelli dei fatti
e questi sarebbero berline con tute rosa
tiriamo su per non dire poi detto allora
secondo me chi stanno bene le palline
[Musica]
quelli che non può che modo
all'inter che ha preceduto per
sicuramente essendo le palline abbinate
line va naturalmente da uno per colore
brutto messaggio diretto bene che le mie
super rosa a karaci ma anche
metallizzato non vede l'ora di vederlo
attivo nel frattempo è diventato una
sorta di color cachi è quello che bello
per l'autista
vedremo mi sembravano così allora
mettiamo mente come volete voi
mettiamo questo questo pigmento qui si
[Musica]
prende di queste cose qui brutta che
umani piacciono a prelevare i suoi capi
di non ferrara ct c'è anche un ramo
della casina run è capitato niente qui
per fortuna fatti questo sly che sto
pagando troppo bene ci siamo mancati
secondo me l'inter e discovery che siamo
una casa e quindi alle sue pagine si sta
comportando bene sin dai prossimi due
metri
[Musica]
addio e dopo vicini takaoma come
in porta va bene un po tenera siamo
vediamo se l'italia non poco ma che buon
profumo di stimolo da barba
vedremo che con i parenti prossimi di un
pigmento giovanissimo guarda che per
colore che gli darà ho scelto proprio
bene e tu non ci fa bene no che tanto
nono con ora in questa volta bello
abbiamo verificato all'ora
[Musica]
così dopo sarà pronto per diventare un
bel garanzini gente ragazzi lo sto
cominciando a far diventare più con più
di un colore di un colore più scuro
[Musica]
ora che magari suo tempo ed ora sono
indeciso però per di mattina sempre
sullo stesso colore messa mi sa che
scelto
vi ho detto cosa mi ha detto er e ancora
che sia ragazzi rossi l'idea quella
stessa cosa di altro che lo schio
[Musica]
pallina lucchini una curiosità uno
scambio con verde a rischiare pronta e
quartieri sono qui si è questa ha chiuso
così felice ora pirano per te che bene
sono le palline più bello in assoluto è
un po speriamo che non spariscano che
non vanificano nello quasi umberto i
cake diamo gioco che diventa con il
viola con me stesso per twitterato aveva
previsto
finalmente lo stiamo facendo diventare
di un colore più scuro blu
mi hai cambiato poco ne ho già preso un
po di dolore rito un pochino e
scoraggiante e non lo spumeggiante testa
l'ha aspettata per favoletta nobile
neronova giappone rovinato sottovoce ma
dai non è giusto basta prezzo questa qui
lo butta via niente
va bene niente nero non ora facciamo il
verde così se tu non si giustificano un
po capitale blenda ricordo niente
aterballetto quindi poi magari non vi
era uno scambio oppure ti esce all'altro
realtà di dio magari fossi in te stai un
pochettino più aperta e un po rischioso
però però voglio vedere come
divertimento di magic giro
[Musica]
non tanto al 62 pinedo chiusi mai più su
scegli tu quindi cerco si aspetta la mia
fa letta questa sera megatone toccando
culturali speculiamo inviterà proprio
guardato poi dopo tutto il giallo che ci
metti non parlare quando quando mi
capite la scegli tu e ammettiamo tutto
il giorno più bello speriamo che
trasformino
[Applauso]
e non basta ecco non mi tiro della
niente è bello e brutto il cattivo
ricomparirà scommetti ma come fai a dire
che vi piace questa cosa qui comparato a
questa che è bellissimo guardarle con
tutte le quali tutto rosa stupendo come
fate a dire che più bello quello questo
più bello mediato desiderio per il verso
la vita è cattivista e una rovinosa e
guarda un po il verde di tormenterà di
nuovo sotto forma di colorante sotto
forma di palline tra cattivissima era
bellissimo anche lo slime adesso vi
contare a tutto verde
continua si è talmente forte la
maledizione del med che potrebbe coprire
mi ha coperto tutto il mondo io gli ho
detto guarda diventato bellissimo not
non mi dire che c'è grigio prova vediamo
sfortunata la vedi tu sei cattiva con me
se lo slime è buono ma non era l'ultimo
turno quindi speriamo che ci capiti
qualcosa che loro video stai per te per
visto che l'ultimo polmone verde di
benzina ed acustico tour non si stavano
solo
esprimo riesco io peraltro basta
dopo che una commissione che la
posizione del barrio della detto tu
adesso non puoi cominciare all'anzhi a
rompere la scatola l'udente poi il
viaggio con tv boy a montecatini per
tutti che io che lo tiene a noi abbiamo
piani che torna da me io te l'ho detto è
terzo io ti ho detto attento perché il
verde di ritorno indietro è infortunato
che è il mio bellissimo sen
giallo con qualche fiore nato anche la
paletta apre di una manetta brutta e poi
sport si crea 8 10 giu scambio 5
la tv una città detto perché avesse
viaggio è di nuovo il verde magari esiti
nuovo scabbia adesso ultimo ciglio
appunti 10 da molti un pigmento chi
chiusi
io invece sto già tutto tranquillo
perché so di avere questo potuto giallo
così bella
ebbene si come no e ancora c'è un
compitino
io mi dimetto aspetta che devo rischiare
vai a quanto ha preso questa buffa
perché non è presente cosa fosse scaduto
che ha avuto più l'ultimo ingrediente
della charles spencer inverte questo non
penso proprio delicato come la terra dai
rosa piaciuto tutto il verde a milis
precisione è diventata una sorta di blu
violetto capisse limpare lo sta
schiarendo ma che diventa decisivo da
uno speriamo che una volta attivo non si
vede al verde proprio per niente
tibaldi siccome sono così finanzi
limiteremo tipo umberto narrativa non si
farà palizzi metraggio valeva la pena
[Applauso]
siete pronti
questo gigantesco è il mio slime cioè
interi era quello di evitare ma abbiamo
scambiato quindi questo è il mio slime
allora il colore fortunatamente non è
diventato verte però è una specie di blu
violetto vedete a un fracco di palline e
gigante non so se si capisce dalla
telecamere ma il gigantesco il colore è
un po particolare però non è male mi
piacciono un sacco i suoni che spa
sentiamo un po fuori hai dato un nome a
questa somma dei commenti
[Musica]
ed eccolo il mio simon bellissimo e
tantissimi fiori fantastici pete mura
quello di evitare che versare il mio
piccolo di lime e come l'ha
soprannominato anita e lo slam polenta
30 gigante allora è un bello soffice
grazie anche alla schiuma da barba che
niente andiamo a sentire subito i rumori
e le cose come sono
sentiamo
[Musica]
bellissimo sembra l'impasto del talento
ne ha da perdere e niente questo è il
mio spline super morbidoso super
allungabile enorme vedete sono super
contento dello slam tra volevo provare a
fare un uso io che squillo in gigante
che ho fatto mi depilo o è talmente
grande che spunta pure il tavolo non si
sa
un sacco alle semifinali questo che il
cavaliere dalla fine guarda aggiungiamo
dobbiamo aspettarci dai infatti la terra
questi del verde come troppo diversa
invece che da gigante angosciosi
diventate qualche vicoli 8 e vinci e
vitale in quanto bellezza inserite verde
lime e ora mi lascio mappato per i
carichi casa si pone proprio idea è
buona visione